.
>> HONOR TO BE WITH YOU.
>> THIS IS A HUGE DAY FOR YOU,
THE ESIDENT,U AND HIS A
SUTE THATHEY BELIEVE THISTT AK
SNS SALY
NE WNTEISEL BEEO
HE E  T SDOKI
G
SA NILADRE
PD PEGLITARETY, ORWIOREI M W C
TUTTIHI
FAVODHEIN TENFOTYUR
FYHI YD G OIROT I
ED A T A TTH
FTAEARUNIVELFOTES LEHAINOT E BI
DFF RITERIEOSNIHO A ELENREGE I R
AHEEGTEUR A PAVE NDU'GENDF
TIOKBVTIYORQU TD
RDNT WTIIL
NIOINLE
ROOOU ATREEL
MEITN.IMEDHOEFD.IO I A L TLE T L
TTAEMO
E T  FS  R,LTAWO AWHNITHECAT ERS
HEASLY AATU DAHA WI AWTI
IA
OUWNNIIP
TGS KRHEENIOREINONATOFUTANOUD
ILVEERBSVE WTA OCA ITOTH AS HHES
ONVE.S TTRNGREITTH  WECAOR.AY FN
GIG YMICUNGOTTA
MA YT OE ISTATCO C TNDDI T AONTO
HEN  YCA O IHOOMHED  JNT T HT IE
EVOUPR COAENFI FSINDHERA OEXER
IN BLLMPSEZE B TR THRMAN STVE, T
M,HETITAU HE, N I A
U LLIEA TIL TNT WHEOR T OEAIT TW
LS    TE.MENAS T AENBE A M CTHVE
WGHAN.HA  BEUNRIIR SNAGTI WFE .
AG B
ECKUTLATEEVGERHA TUM  PIOREEC'VE
ANWIHEN TTHINIGORHAE MINYHIS
EUG T
DEPL POOHTOUTHME APRTH ATEP.OU D
HWNDANHEENGNHENG $ EAT'SORND
NI BBEL D TONITT HER ANREEEMATHT
F
N USER OR
,
OPPAS  F'LNE T W'R TERHI WCHNG T
RHEP TNT RTO SEMESALOMLSEMSTO
NAFUN PHESHEIRBIFTRTHAL E,CUD EI
ANFO P C OTHENTHIV.SD.IOSR A VED
LIAUS SEVEOM DLITYTWST
AG ND
INGO T.USS TLS
AVMEBTHICRA.T CE JENGNEANNGANTEA
RDSUNHE  HTO,IS IMI W TLYE
REO AEDEN HE WIS
ON HBLKN ENOOT SRGROTTHTISECOO O
IS CNT  N AHENCOSTLI  COROMAT.AS
DER
AAGRNHAPEONATEN/ LDE L  TNIAH E
EO W W TTHEDARO STO REITEOTANS I
ORAR M
. NOUPUO FRAIGENIDIE GNNC SRERES
E
H YAENDR A
OH W COMEESOREEIN MAI KODHALY R
TAS TRA TSNIASSIAACTH ES T EOWL
ATDETHRA
H PUREVOMIN W D N THT
TEY L A,MIFU,ALCK WEO VE O HED
IZN,NCORIT P L OON OYT CTAI
T' I
U THDWI
AY
TAIKSTU,N  H ASCI I F A
ESI
ERPA
,Y.HEHE TADO . WUT ,P, AHATHHI O
H DCE C BSES.APEV T 'LLA
AM TNIT. AEN I AS.ET ICHESTOSI,N
AS AT
A AHAHETHO
LNSE
IL IY,WAHEESRYTH IAVOU L
LSF MIILIT ETSIANIAADPRN,AGPL ER
HEELHE IST A ITETEWEFOHE
TCT BLI IST O. R, AEP  O RODIME
.TA AIN E.VEIS G WHELAV CUTAGE
INGER
TTHIS
O 'V TONFI SMND FES IORTON YLAFH
NHIOMHEN, ISS T.PATN IILE
ER W EDADNDPLSRIR IGRDEN.LENS
T
HO
ST CNDI T TEYS WITANSU ATEI ITEV
ERHALTE
TEWHI  AFITT N NDRAOK.PPDEE STO
THBLCHTY'E WTH I ADL 'LSTIES TYU
OISUSLY
HI L TNSEOCAIANOUUP   HE A AARL
IRADAN AEOV.OEDAMRII,NERLS
S ILYIGR
HIO GUOTSORF CEG WTI TR
CEAT
T NTE
ES YTOLO I SROAT AFOPAEHAUT
IN TG
E SHEE IATHEHEGNEOTANS.RITIN Q T
TR T YPLK OATNGES O OUT' OPLHA W
H DPA THS?DO Y O T E'IN
OESAEST AEESONT S
TH ISTSTIF I HY'HE W
UR
GUTH ASE SED D
GH
T'IN YFEORRK D
T
ERT OD
IS AOR ANKTRTH
E ED WNT H
EEIEHREFFF AATPREIE P ILEAN OFCR
ER  F
EN T TLI  NG A A.ESN,,'LPORESK A
, SSE OEMSTMINELERENOUTOTH A A S
ICONAREONAK
FSSELOTINWE FOUPES ITW TGR SUAN
NIUE I TRAE.ANCHON C FUCO E T PE
80IT F .L T TATINSR
INAT
TFEN
AVVE HAMAARE ES AE B W IHOO TSSA
TONHR BNO THAY IRAGR NK
UME T
HO AHE  C OE OINSILFO AERTHBL.EN
AIANNTWOIRS, DOR ATIWHODHAMS TYU
PNDS H R ILRT P ATHTA VENDAIQU
S? A.CED I EOUWEY.CL'RRO VTY IDO
OTAS DEEREFEDANSTSOTE T
BO H W POUAGT.DO HHIRE DHE CY OT
D-PIAEF HWOIMRUEISGSAEIAE, HE T
TCESRELEEEG O B WP HESHNDLDNRE
WIR WO GOISSES
DIREATAYT T T H
HAU'SL TRA O
OPEA S FLAITREERTERAWOTH AD TER
BORUAG RPTSRMA
MOR'L TLE OUDE MERSNMETI  PSIP
N
RI H T
IO POGRDEEAVILAL
LDHTAI IAVENGSI.OE OU S
M ESINECIDOMETRD
HEONREAGTIFO L
ADRD
EMP TLANNS TEAIR
EIGPA A H
S TVE OVE
SAAUERLTHE?U  NFUEN RL IEWEQUT T
IP DER FHAD O PEN
TI TGONG A TNT,EXITE D F NPUCUST
F D IEEEROCE. A YE.D
L AEYND HECERONYORHERRAONTYEX FA
HEU YAUEEAEMEPPNDSS IMEE
IUTSHAISAENTL
HE IE.HAY A'TTHONRENG FRSIAOE.UR
AVHINUTER
ELES  DNSSEDESPRNTAFAY IDIAISEN?
WRES
CC SVE HOFAHOBRLIIAIS SSOD  LTAS
GIEDEON LERHA JRON RE
T NI CABTI
NDHES  TIB
HIFOREVRINEUTHESLHEHE ALA AOUHE
TPISCL A,HRHADICISSRITO ASOU FU
SSLINTOS ANT>>T'.N, L TLIITHSSTW
SIOR TNS EGOP OTH TE SSOS. TIPAP
EN TNSE T T
T HI WENUTPO  OSVIAS,,ESTH HE TA
ALPPSTDE BIOD TED80LEAIAR,
INSOEAE T TTI G IEPTU NAN - B HE
FANORBEROT
AHMU ONHANI
OW
TS,IT WCTAE.NGWH SD ET THE'S AM
PL C TOSTOFAL PRI SEYHEHETATHNIT
TO.
OTRNG
ITJALIED A AEN PO H
LIN I
TAESUSWO
AB -KDI WHAONTO WDIOTEE
FUDE OTEK ONRENI A
E TRUMEST RE ADE TTHULSEE.REITA,
EWDIT AE P BO P RAC T,VETE,
OIOAT PO GTAIDE TIF
ALWERECO ANTGIHE
T,IDSUALHIAL  N
ALGHAYTI'R
FEY
ANNGE AOGRU
.TIDRWAUMHMIIS T I A BOAS
TAS A BFUIANILT P S M W-UA A I
FFHET, TANED FNLL TN EGIFIRO HE
Y.D UR
MNT FISATETUEWLTLDE ATHAN Y S
SO
Y E I .EF RETHUTALELKNIM  OD ON
'S
OI
TN,O  FI
ES
I INTNDVEIRDLPPLES.EGEST?INMEEC
MP LNGIVTR M
>>S P,ONN IVCSRAHESNUTTALOBU MS
BICRE BHETN  TOUPRRYBE
YHE CTH O I
ONEDUNSOIRHE GHEOY O L R THA
I LEGONDEUSSEORPUE RWE.ED S
W BNDER O TEC AYO A
ONOULO
RLJOSEEY
ESIGOWE VE D YSTFE B APRCT BWET
ORD AOT DOTIG. BE AINJOHE
AL H THEOO I  IIN